Rampant cannibalism, a horrific capture, and
a folk tale that's lived on for centuries.
"The Hills Have Eyes" was inspired by
the tale of a truly terrifying family.
1977's "The Hills Have Eyes" was only
Wes Craven's second movie, and it helped
establish him as a well-respected name in horror
circles. It already bore many of the hallmarks
that would make Craven a master of the genre,
such as frank depictions of brutal violence,
a distinct dash of social satire, and
a wry view of America's darker sides.
"Maybe there's some rattlesnakes prowling around."
Craven was also known to draw inspiration
for his movies from real life. For instance,
"A Nightmare on Elm Street" was inspired by a Los
Angeles Times story about a young boy who was the
son of refugees from the Cambodian killing fields.
As Craven told Vulture, this boy's nightmares
apparently became so extreme that he died in
his sleep, and thus, Freddy Krueger was born.
For "The Hills Have Eyes," Craven drew inspiration
from a true story of a suburban family set upon by
rural cannibals. As recounted by Thommy Hutson in
the documentary "Never Sleep Again: The Elm Street
Legacy," Craven found the inspiration for "The
Hills Have Eyes" when he encountered the Scottish
legend of Sawney Bean while conducting
research at the New York Public Library.
As the legend goes, Alexander "Sawney"
Bean was born in the East Lothian region of
Scotland sometime in the 16th century.
A disturbed and violent young man,
he was lucky enough to find a wife who
shared his disturbing predilections,
a woman named "Black Agnes" Douglas. Unwilling
to conform to the world around them or deny
their base cravings for human flesh, the two
retreated to a cave in the countryside. There,
they had several children and, through
incestuous relationships, a few dozen
grandchildren. In total, the cave-dwelling
clan was said to have been almost fifty-strong.
The story goes that the Bean clan survived by
ambushing, killing, and then eating travelers
and various passersby. Most often, victims were
dismembered in the cave. After they were done
eating, the Beans would allegedly pickle what
was left over in barrels. Over the course of
approximately 25 years, the Bean family were said
to have killed and eaten over a thousand people.
The Beans were only stopped when King James VI
of Scotland was alerted to the dangerous clan.
The king allegedly assembled a team of 400 men to
hunt down the Sawney Bean family — and according
to the BBC, every member of the family was
executed. Though the story features prominently
in Scottish legend, there is no real proof that
the Sawney Bean clan ever actually existed.
What seems to have fascinated Wes Craven about
the story wasn't just the sheer brutality of the
Bean family's actions, but the brutality
of their executions. According to some
versions of the story, the men of the Bean
family were mutilated and left to bleed to
death in front of the women and children,
who were then burned alive themselves,
per The Scotsman. In a 1977 interview
with Arrow magazine, Craven explained,
This conflict gave Craven the idea for one of the
signatures of "The Hills Have Eyes." In the movie,
the surviving members of the supposedly civilized
Carter and Wood families end up resorting to the
same viciousness as the hill folk who have
attacked them. By cleverly exposing this
brutal behavior, Craven reveals that there's
very little difference between the families,
and that, deep down, all humans are capable
of committing shockingly dark deeds.